when you need your blade sharpened the
best thing to do is have a couple of
blades on hand so that you can take one
off and then put on the new blade and
while that way can be used for another
eight to ten to twelve hours of use then
you take the blade you took off to the
local hardware store and most of the
local hardware store should be able to
put a nice edge on you and it's
important having a sharp blade not only
keeps the plants healthy but it costs
you less and fuel in the long run so the
first thing I like to do is grab a piece
of cardboard is something lay down on no
matter how much you try to clean your
concrete pad it's always going to be
dirty and if that's a concern for you
this makes a nice surface to lay down on
one thing i like to keep with me when
i'm changing blades and what I'm taking
them off is a welding glove you can pick
these up at your local hardware store a
large rag works well I like a glove
because I can actually hold on to the
blade there's no chance of its slipping
out of my hand when you're taking a
blade off if you're not holding on to it
it's going to want to turn on you you
never want to be use a socket to take a
blade off if you're not holding on to it
when you're laying on your back trying
to take a blade off sometimes
counterclockwise and clockwise becomes
confusing so what I do is before I use
my tool I'll make sure that it's
loosening up or tightening down
depending on what I'm doing and I'll set
it before hand so when I crawl
underneath the machine I'm already set
up to do it okay
now when you take them out what I like
to do is just mark it right top on it
whatever helps you put that blade back
in the same way I like to use the center
block is something to hold the top of
the lower down this way you can access
the blade safely just remember with
these small rotary mowers you don't want
to leave them tip back for very long gas
and oil can move on you and they'll
start spilling out remove your blade
move your tools to the side and lift up
your cinder block and set the mower back
down until you're ready to put your
blade back on